歌えとパッと見なかっツボっぽいですねまぁりを気にせず全力で歌って歌うまになる
大きな声を出してもへっちゃら70%減ボリュームダウン
号すごい歌エットってやつ未だにこのひと通りなんですけどこれ過去の中で声を出すと
ボリュームがすごいダウンしてしまいます
もうほどラオウほど
おおーーあああああ
ああああああ
今これ外してなかったら多分カメラ壊れてます始めそうですなるほど
音を70%も食べさせるのかすごいなあというわけでこれを使うと人に迷惑をかけず
大きな音出せるというものでございますこの厨房とする自分の声を聞きながらもできる
というやつか
これで自分の声すごいクリアに聞こえるらしいですはいこんな感じです
ああああああ
あおおおおーすごいでしょ軍の声の自分の組だけクリーンに聞こえますこれゲット覚え
て喋ってるんで外すとすごい声がでかいんですけどこれ受けてるけど結構ついされて
聞こえると思いませんこれすごいなあああいうわけで今日これ70%をそうカット
できるということならねーっもっといろんなもんだろ
音がカットできるんじゃないかと思いますねちょっと音がでかそうなものを放って買っ
てきました二弾をたが出稼ぎで聞こえないような音をひょっとしたらこれを通せば
聞こえるんじゃないかと思いまして直単にうるさいものを何か買ってきたので実際に名
やってレベルで音が大きいものをこの中で鳴らすで見てボレーくらい音が小さくなるの
か確かめてみようと思います
これでレベル g ですからねまあこれも苦情レベルでうるさいぞ
皆さん今の音を覚えてくださいこの音を果たして歌いとの中で聞くと本どれぐらい本当
になるのかちょっと聞いてみてください
いきますできます
[音楽]
上をここまでおとう閉じ込めデイズとはなかなかですよ上は何とか抑えた
何か僕ちょっと経験つはこういう小さい奴ほどうるさいんですよたぶん1回だしてみ
ます
[音楽]
うそれも歌いと使うとどれだけ小さくなるのでしょうか
あっていっ
入れ兄は m リデルってこれだって打っても入らないもう
失格
[音楽]
防犯ブザーも結構とがあるゴッドどうなってんだこれ外れないよねっ
こここういう銅座わかんないやとれてアソコは元夫となったじゃないか
このと皆さん覚えておいてください
これが果たして唱えてるどれだけ小さくなるのかやってみましょう
ハッハー
いいいい
そうめっちゃ小さい誰
ran
[音楽]
うざいよ
クラッカーもなかなかうるさいと思うんですけどもまぁこんな感じの音ですねえっ
ですがこれを唱えとの中でやるといきます
おすごいすごいすごい以後全然音が鳴らなかったやんってすごいねなんでもとが消せる
の管クラッカーの綺麗な音も聞こえるのかもしれない
[音楽]
バッハ
ああ
このバック付の音を止めれば僕は本当にすごいと思いますこれ
いかに音を小さめられるかが今回のえっ
この途中止まる本当にならん
[音楽]
はぁっ
eaa
[音楽]
me
ううっうぅうう
car
uh